hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the practice festival the
Masters edition its young shift of Duda
versus Alvarez of fallujah I don't even
have to point out that it's wild game
since the two of them are playing I bet
you were already expecting it to be a
wild game I just have a little bit of
info regarding the candidates tournament
is gonna start in March
it seems that Russia put a ban on people
from China from entering Russia so I
think learn and won how might have a
might have some problems actually
attending the the candidates tournament
as is being played in your cutting book
in Russia but I don't think there's a
very likely chance that they will not be
able to enter so you know but just in
case it happens you will know why there
are six players instead of eight players
in the candidates tournament although it
does seem very unlikely that you know
who wouldn't allow to chess players from
entering their country regardless of the
disease they're carrying but you know
we'll just have to wait and see and also
I've acquired Allen's new book the mind
master I just started reading it today
got through first twenty pages right now
before actually recording this video and
it's actually a very well-written book
and it seems like an awesome book I'm
planning on finishing it tomorrow so if
you were considering acquiring it or you
know you had doubts it is a good book so
just in case you're wondering now that
means said let's check out the game do
that with the white pieces opens with c4
the English opening is on the board we
have c6 9 f3 and d5 striking in the
center sort of the coral conjure up
against the English with III and the
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now II 6
with b3 preparing to VN get to the dark
square bishop and the bishop to d6 now
Bishop to b2 by Duda with castles by
future and Queen to c2 just continue in
development and now II five since white
allowed it why not you know or I already
have a way of developing your light
square bishop as well Bishop to e2 by
Duda not even bothering a border to play
d3 to prevent e4
he just continues and he basically
invites efore which fallujah of course
does it's I mean why wouldn't you play
this you free or dark square bishop as
well and you force whites to play some
fishy moves so bishops or in Knights the
g5 and now there is one game in the
database were Bishop to fi was played
but here future plays h6 he says okay
that so we're looking Knight get it away
from there
and it is as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so what happens next
we have eight four do the offers up
offers a full night and we reach the
position from the thumbnail so what
happens if then I dis captured well if
characters captures you have to go
somewhere with the knight most probably
Knight h7 and then f4 is very strong now
because you pretty much keep this night
out of the game and your plan is now
well now you're just gonna Castle you're
gonna maybe double rooks here bring the
other rock over to h1 and you're gonna
have a very strong attack here with this
night pretty much unable to go to go
anywhere if Bishop here you can just
continue with the g5f five and so on
the problem is for example capturing on
poisson loses the mate right away so
that's out of the question
so f4 would be incredibly strong here
and the white would definitely have
compensation for his sacrificed piece so
after h4 future does not accept the
sacrifice he goes rook to e8 rook to e8
instead just continues development and
now Duda starts Rema nuvaring the knight
Knight back to h3 at we Knights to a6
and now a3 taking away the be for square
from few just night and now sort of an
unprincipled move but it is justified
here future plays D captures and c4 and
it is the strongest move recommended by
the engine so fallujah makes the the
correct decision now usually you do not
want to release the tension in the
center you want to keep your opponent
chained intact but here like I said it's
justified because after captures you
will either ruin White's pawn structure
or
after Bishop captures on c4 which was
played in the game b5 so the bishop has
to go back Bishop to e2 and now before
this is where fiducia finds his counter
play for the for ruining of his own pawn
structure
night back to D 1 and now B captures on
a3 with bestial characters and now night
the b4 so this was his plan with this
night to a6 maneuver and now you either
leave this night on b4 which is a
monster or you eliminate it but you have
to you have to part ways with your own
bishop pair so dude oh of course
decides for Bishop characters on b4 with
Bishop characters on b4 end now g3
preparing the eater castle or maybe
castle artificially with King F 1 2 G 2
we will see depending on what black
plays and here Knight to g4
here Fallujah has some ideas of playing
Queen to f6 which will put additional
pressure on f2 for a moment ok it's
guarded but it's useful piece to have
and also it could come with an attack on
the rook on a 1 so here look to a 2
getting away from this nasty attack and
also it will provide additional the
defense to the d2 pond which is which is
a backward spawn since Duda decided
willingly not to play this pawn to d3 we
have Queen to f6 now continuing
development and now while you could
castle castling just runs into g5 which
could be very strong for black or you
know could be a very double-edged game
well whichever way you would like to
well phrase that came to f1 by Duda yeah
he prefers the sort of artificially
Castle with maybe King F 1 2 G 2 will be
a very safe Square for the King and then
black might be a bit discouraged on
playing g5 since opening of the H file
might favor now white due to the rook
being on on the H file so Bishop the f5
continuing development adding more
defense to the e4 pawn and now kink the
g2 and now the roof might stay here the
rook might come into into the game
depending on what future plays with rook
a to d8 and now Knight to c3 as there's
a lot of pressure here on the D do pawn
so Knight c3 blocking the bishops at
acted upon and now a5 just the
solidifying that pawn here white was
unable to capture it on the previous
move because the rook was were also very
useful here guarding the pawn here and
if you move it just the rook captures
would be it would be devastating so
tonight's the F
for an excellent square for doulas night
and now Queen to e5
now fuchsia needs to make room for his
pieces he needs to improve here maybe
play rugby ated bring the other Rudy sit
maybe bring the Elric over to date and
then breakthrough with g5 so look the c1
now the rook is no longer needed on the
H file and rook the d6 also the c6 pawn
is now defended by the rook so a very
useful move we have Queen back to d1 and
Knight back to f6 now there's the threat
of just Bishop characters ng4 so Knight
back to f6 and the now h5 grabbing more
space on the Kings side and rook 8d 8th
now really piling up on the d2 points so
this Knight is pretty much stuck on c3
we have Knight back to be 1 so now you
are attacking it three times but you are
also defending three times with the rook
the knight and the Queen and here the
situation on the clock is nine minutes
for Duda and 15 minutes for fuchsia and
they still have to reach time control
it's only moved 27 so 13 more moves are
needed to reach time control we have g5
so here you pretty much have to react H
captures and g6 on pass on F captors and
g6 and now Queen to h1 and going for the
h6 pawn but came to g7 future defense
and now Knights the a3 preparing to
bring the knight into the game via c4
but now Fallujah says ok it's the bishop
pair is no longer useful here it's time
to eliminate the night the night could
become stronger than the bishop now so
Bishop captures an a3 rook captures and
the rook might also be very vulnerable
here for example if this Queen jumps
down to be 2 for example with a double
attack on the pawn and on the rook
white could have some problems so first
g5 pushing even further on the Kings
side Knight h5 check we have characters
captures and the now comes rook captures
and d2 and here Fallujah is up upon and
the Duda has they decided very very
carefully what what he's about to do he
could go for something like Quinta a1 he
could try and trade off a pair of rooks
with rook to d1 with the Queen and the
bishop defending it but he decides to
win back material with rook captures on
c6 and this
doesn't work for him so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
strongest move for future while I give
you a couple of seconds and while I also
have a nice sip of my water so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that this
bishop was in the way of the rooks well
planned to attack the f2 square so when
you put this idea with the idea that the
this rook is analyzed squared together
you find the move Bishop to d7 you don't
really care about the rook you just want
to move your bishop away from the F file
without wasting time so you you attack
the rook rook now has to move problem is
if you move let's say rook c1 or
something yes rook to g6 looks very
interesting but let's say you move back
rook to see one rookie fate is extremely
strong now you have to defend it let's
say we go rook to f1 now Queen B - the
move we discuss now comes with an attack
on the rook and also a triple attack on
the f2 pawn black just wins here so a
Duda tried rook to g6 with check King to
h7 and now again you have a problem for
example let's say you you Bishop the
gate is coming this this will be deadly
so let's say you try something like rook
rook to a6 you you move the rook you
hope nothing bad happens here black
actually has this very nice rook
captures on f2 that's the problem in
most of these lines King captures rook
the f8 with track king g2 and now again
Queen to be - with check you're not
interested in the rook you're gonna
check mate white King's you want to look
to echo Queen to f2 will be checkmate so
there are big problems here so it's hard
hard to decide what to do here
Queen the c1 was played trying to get
the Queen into the game also now the
rook is under attack but the problem is
this Bishop the e8 now comes with with
full force which is what what he plays
now the rook is under attack if you move
the rook the Bishop is under attack
also the rooks now defend each other and
there wasn't really much Duda could have
done here so there really isn't a good
move here you're gonna lose material so
do that try to capture some a5 give up
the rook this way Queen captures on a5
and now Queen to c4 of course a
threatening Queen to g8 mate but
well Fallujah is winning here so just
capturing the rook is sufficient for a
win here but feel free to pause the
video and try to find the move future
plate which is just a bit more forcing
well while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it
congratulations and again spotting the
the sacrifice we already mentioned it's
a rook captures an f2 for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
rook captures an f2 with check this is
what future played King captures and now
Queen to f5 with check and it was in
this position that young she subdued I
resigned the game and because now he
just well he basically traded down it's
pretty much pointless to play here and
there are no tricks there are no
complications the material is too too
low on the board and there is nothing to
be done here so it was in this position
unmoved 39 one move before time control
that young she's to do the resign the
game and yet another great victory for
four younger leaders of Arusha like I
said here if you move the King let say
King here now you capture characters
captures and you're just up a whole rook
there are no tricks here sorry not Queen
captures but King captures you don't
want to run into Queen c7 check here you
don't have you don't have any options
you will be able to deliver a few checks
but black will just simply hide and
that's just so check here maybe if you
check your rook and block the Queen
defends the rook and that's that's
that's excellent white white is getting
made it so after the squinter five move
with check Duda resigned and what a game
by the run by two of them remember it's
never it's not enough for one player to
play well to create a beautiful game
both players have to do their best and
we also have the standings after round
seven since we I don't think we showed
the standings all that often so here are
the standings with it in first place
since he defeated fallujah and that
beautiful win achieving a winning
position after 12 moves with it with 507
then now a negative it away now it has a
future with four out of seven
David Anton de haro and
she's of Duda in same Shanklin with
three and a half out of seven Marku
stronger in Divina vara in Pinto
harikrishna with three out of seven and
in last place Neil's Grand alias at
which two and a half out of seven so
yeah that's those are the standings and
I would just like to mention for those
of you who are still asking when the
subscribers who video will be finished
very soon we had some problems the first
editor that was editing it couldn't
finish it and then we had to start over
and then a whole whole thing got
complicated but it should be finished
fairly quickly so so sorry about that I
was really hoping to post it much sooner
than in the previous two years but it is
just not never simple to finish it but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and then some of the well
info I've provided before and after the
game I would like to thank Harold Klein
Frank Lloyd unease Bashara a shock
banger and a gorilla for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Prague
chess masters continuing of course the
Paul Morphy saga end to check up on your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day